In a recent video, we looked at why I
believe that Muhammad existed, even
though some in the West insist he is a
later fabrication created to provide the
Arab Empire with a hagiographical
founding story.
I essentially offered three arguments.
One, there are very early non-Muslim
references to Muhammad, the oldest of
which is only 2 years after his death.
By way of comparison, the earliest
non-Christian reference
to Jesus Christ is about 60 years after
his crucifixion. Two, if no Muhammad
existed, then no descendants of Muhammad
existed, either. So, how can we
understand the Shia, who have been
fighting and warring against the Sunni
since the 7th century on the claim that
only Muhammad's descendants can lead the
Muslim world as caliphs?
Three, although the Hadith was written
down between 120 to 250 years following
Muhammad's death, hence why those who
claim Muhammad never existed dismiss
them as unreliable, they do not behave
the way one would expect forgeries to
behave, namely by presenting Muhammad in
glowing terms. Rather, they show him
with all his warts, to the point that
countless Muslims over the centuries
have left Islam primarily because of the
way Muhammad is depicted in the Hadith.
So, what kind of forgeries meant to help
Islam's founding story are these?
So, much for why I believe a Muhammad
figure existed.
Now, let's turn to and evaluate the
counterarguments against his existence.
There's only one problem.
I don't know any of them. Nor do I care
to know any of them. Nor do I need to
know any of them to dismiss them. Why,
you may ask? Because I do know one
thing. Without hearing any of them, I
already know none of them can, by their
very nature, be conclusive. None of them
can be incontrovertible, incontestable,
or irrefutable. And this is really the
grand point I'd like to make here. There
is nothing in pre-modern history,
certainly when it comes to people and
events that are 14 centuries old, such
as Muhammad and Islam, that can be
proven or disproven. It's simply
impossible. Sure, one can make
arguments, but arguments are not
incontrovertible proof. And short of
that, short of concrete irrefutable
proof, people will always believe
whatever is most emotionally satisfying
to them or fits their needs.
To be clear, I'm not saying that the
arguments against Muhammad's are wrong.
For all I know, they may be right. Maybe
Muhammad never existed. Rather, what I
am saying is that they cannot be proven
one way or another on a scientific
level, as pure objective facts that must
be acknowledged by those who would count
themselves among rational human beings.
There will always be room for another
interpretation, for a counter claim.
Why? Because it's history, literally,
and we can't go back in time to prove
what really did and did not happen.
Let's, for example, look at what appears
to be one of the main arguments against
Muhammad's existence.
And I know this because many of those
people telling me to consult the works
of Dr. Jay Smith mentioned it. If I
rightly understood it, it's the claim
that there are no early records or
archaeological evidence for Mecca, even
though Mecca is obviously pivotal for
Muhammad's existence. No Mecca, no
Muhammad.
My first reaction to this is the famous
dictum, absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence. Just because we
don't possess the evidence for something
does not mean it never existed. What if
Mecca was once on dozens of ancient
maps, all of which are now, like most of
history, lost? Is there proof that that
cannot be the case? No, by nature, there
is no such proof. The opposite argument
is also true. There are probably many
civilizations and important people that
we've never even heard of.
Can you, for example, imagine how
different our understanding of the past
would be, how utterly bizarre history
might seem if the Great Library of
Alexandria and its world-changing
contents weren't torched?
At any rate, the argument against
Mecca's existence kind of reminds me of
the ancient city of Troy from Homer's
epic, the Iliad, with Achilles, Hector,
Helen, etc. For centuries, all serious
scholars and archaeologists maintained
that Troy was purely mythological, that
it never existed except as a
make-believe stage for Homer's Iliad.
Then, in the late 1800s, nearly 3,000
years after the recorded sacking of
Troy, an amateur archaeologist, Heinrich
Schliemann, found it in modern-day
Turkey.
This is a perfect example of how absence
of evidence was never evidence of
absence. But just to show you how
nebulous the discipline of history truly
is, when I first heard about
Schliemann's discovery of Troy in a
classics course I took back in the '90s,
all I remember thinking about then is,
how do we know what he found was Troy?
How do we know it wasn't another,
perhaps wholly unknown or forgotten
civilization? Such is the messiness of
history.
All this leads to my other main point,
why the Muhammad never existed claim is
a very weak, if not futile, polemic
against Islam. It comes down to this,
because very little can be unequivocally
proven or disproven in history, guess
what? People, in this case Muslims, will
always embrace, and justifiably so, the
version that best suits their needs, in
this case that Muhammad existed. It's
really as simple as that. Want proof?
Guess who else, even more scholars, have
for approximately two centuries, not
just a few decades, been issuing
academic book after academic book to
prove that he never existed? Jesus
Christ. Has the Christian world been
rocked? Has Christianity died out? Have
you ever heard of a single person who
went from being a practicing, observant
Christian to apostatizing simply and
only because they were convinced by
academic arguments that Christ never
existed? Yeah, me, neither.
By the way, and interestingly enough, my
contention that people will always adopt
those historical arguments that best
suit their needs works both ways. If the
followers of the prophet will simply
shrug off the non-existence polemic
without bothering to look into it, those
who dislike or are hostile to the
prophet will jump on it. For example,
are you readily willing to look into and
believe claims that Muhammad never
existed because you are an objective
seeker of truth, or is it because you
dislike and are happy to embrace any
argument against Muhammad? That is
because you don't like him, and the
notion that he never existed is very
satisfying on several levels. The simple
way to answer this question is by asking
another.
For example, if you're a Christian, have
you read and tried to grapple with all
the many claims against Christ's
existence, which by nature should be a
far greater consequence to you than
claims about this Muhammad? I bet you
haven't. Indeed, I bet that if you ever
heard that there were arguments against
Christ's existence, you dismissed them
in your mind as products of bitter
atheists and anti-Christians looking to
undermine the Christian faith, arguments
unworthy of your attention as a
Christian. You may even, as I am now
arguing, have instinctively concluded
that whatever such arguments, none of
them can be irrefutably proven, so why
bother looking into them?
If you thought any of that, I'm here to
tell you that I agree. But I'm also here
to tell you that whatever the reason for
you, as a Christian, not being
interested in, much less rocked by,
claims that Jesus never existed are the
same for Muslims when it comes to
Muhammad, except times 10. Remember,
whereas you may fancy yourself an
objective person who is open to
evaluating evidence from any, including
non-Christian, sources, for Muslims, a
non-Muslims are the de facto enemy who
will never cease trying to destroy
Islam.
The Quran itself warns Muslims that,
quote, "Never will the Jews or
Christians be pleased with you until you
follow their faith." End quote. That's
2:120. So, when Christians and Jews come
along and say, "Hey, you dumb Muslims,
guess what? Your prophet never even
existed." And considering all that I've
already pointed out, including that such
claims cannot be proven, how rocked by
this assertion do you think Muslims
really are?
As an avid and long-time observer of
Arabic and Islamic media, I can tell you
that responses to the Muhammad is a myth
claim vary between indifference to
mockery. Muslims either ignore or laugh
at it, the very same way Christians
ignore or laugh at the Jesus never
existed claim.
Again, you may say, "But if Muslims only
took the time to look into the arguments
for Muhammad's non-existence, surely
they would come around." To which again
I respond, "So, why haven't you, a
Christian, read and seriously evaluated
the arguments and claims against
Christ's existence?" Your rationale is
theirs, and so we go in circles.
By the way, my argument that in the
absence of absolute proof, which is
almost always the case when it comes to
questions of history, people will always
opt for the historical interpretation
that best suits their needs, hasn't even
begun to factor in the powerful faith
element involved in questions about
religion or religious figures, as in the
current case.
If secular people will adopt a
historical interpretation that is most
emotionally satisfying, religious people
will do so on an even more extreme
level. That's because for religious
folk, questions about the past are
further tied up with their faith. Just
as Christian belief in Jesus is
ultimately rooted in faith, not this or
that historical record, so too is Muslim
belief in Muhammad ultimately rooted in
faith. So, it's a double whammy. Think
about it. Do you really expect believers
to be moved by the claims of
non-believers, especially when those
claims can't be proven, and those
non-believers making those claims, in
this case those infidels, are already
seen as committed enemies of Islam who
will stop at nothing to destroy it?
Hence why, and with all due respect, I
marvel at anyone who thinks the claim
that Muhammad never existed is
revolutionary and somehow going to rock
the Muslim world to its core. It hasn't,
and it won't. Trust me.
Having said all that, and to reiterate,
my purpose in making this video is not
to attack or even deny the claims that
Muhammad never existed. Nor is this a
personal attack on Dr. Jay Smith, whose
name I mentioned, or any of the other
proponents of the Muhammad myth. Far be
it. I'm sure they all have good reason
for saying what they say. And if you
personally believe that Muhammad never
existed, that's fine by me. I've already
given you my reasons for believing that
a Muhammad figure existed, and I'm a
live and let live kind of guy.
Rather, my point is that claims against
Muhammad, whatever their merits, cannot
by nature be proven and are therefore at
best academic and totally
inconsequential to Muslims, just as and
for the same reasons that arguments
against Jesus Christ's existence have
been academic and totally
inconsequential amongst Christians.
Please don't underestimate the
psychological element involved here.
If you believe that Muhammad never
existed, that's very likely because you
already dislike him. Hence, any argument
against him will take on a strong
quality in your mind. But it's for this
very same reason that the exact opposite
occurs amongst Muslims. Because they
love Muhammad, any argument against him,
especially one that cannot be proven,
will be seen as a pathetic attempt by
those infidels against Islam. In this
sense, Islam's nearly 2 billion Muslims
are like the world's 2.5 billion
Christians who, without a second
thought, laugh at and dismiss claims
that Christ never existed.
Put differently, it's ultimately because
you are against Muhammad that you are
interested in and convinced by
subjective arguments against him. And
it's ultimately because Muslims are for
Muhammad that they will never be
interested in, much less convinced by
the same subjective arguments.
What are ultimately subjective claims
against a religious figure appear very
powerful only because you, the subject,
are personally against that religious
figure. If you're for that religious
figure, they become laughable.
Okay, so you're an avowed foe of Islam
who would see it swept up in the dustbin
of history. Hence why you were so happy
to jump on the Muhammad never existed
bandwagon. So, what now? I'll tell you
what now. Whoever is interested in
effectively opposing Islam must do so at
its own game. That's the way it's always
been and the and the way it's always
going to be. You must embrace the Muslim
paradigm and accept Islam's first
premise, that the Quran, the Sira,
Hadith, etc., in a word, Islam's
scriptures, do indeed contain the
teachings of Muhammad and his God. But
then you must show how such teachings
contradict reason, logic, decency,
morality, and especially godliness.
Such is the original approach, the only
tried and true polemic that has from the
first century following Muhammad's
death, via the writings of John of
Damascus, arguably history's first
polemicist against Islam, till the
present moment been challenging and
convincing Muslims that theirs is a
false prophet.
On the other hand, merely insisting that
he never existed may be personally
satisfying, but it's also a way of
putting yourself out of the debate
altogether, rendering yourself totally
moot.
So, there it is, my two cents on
Muhammad's existence. Let me know what
you think in the comments. Bye.